tomará sus funciones como presidente el
primero de enero del 2023 sin embargo el
primer día de Lula después de su vector
electoral fue frenético en Sao Paulo
recibió el presidente de Argentina
Alberto Fernández con Lula compartimos
una misma mirada sobre la necesidad de
integración en América Latina me dio la
gran alegría de contarme que la primer
visita que va a ser Va a ser Argentina
además de hablar con líderes
latinoamericanos entre ellos Andrés
Manuel López Obrador quien lo invitó a
visitar México el 24 de noviembre
estaría que nos encontráramos aquí en la
Ciudad de México
Lula mantuvo conversaciones con su
homólogo estadounidense Joe biden
los dos líderes discutieron la sólidas
relación entre Estados Unidos y Brasil y
se comprometieron a continuar trabajando
como socios para abordar desafíos
comunes incluida la lucha contra el
cambio climático salvaguardar la
seguridad alimentaria promover la
inclusión y la democracia y gestionar la
migración regional uno de los diálogos
más simbólicos de la jornada fue con el
francés Emmanuel macron quien no ha
visitado Brasil durante la presidencia
bolsonaro ha sido un día tan feliz
porque hemos restaurado la democracia en
nuestro país
tengo que decirle que no podía esperar
este momento en el que podamos relanzar
una asociación estratégica que haga
justicia a nuestra historia en los
desafíos que tenemos por delante es una
gran noticia para nosotros la
ambientalista aliada de Lula Marina
Silva dijo que el presidente pretende
enviar una representación a la cop 27
que se celebrará la próxima semana en
Egipto la misma que será no oficial
porque aún no ha asumido el cargo podría
incluir el flamante